Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je pense que beaucoup
d’entre vous se reconnaîtront,
mais je fais partie de cette catégorie de
personnes qu’on appelle des idéalistes,
des empêcheurs de tourner en rond,
toujours en quête d’une manière
d’améliorer le monde,
d’en faire un monde plus juste
où il fait bon vivre et grandir.
Je vais vous raconter
comment cette quête, justement,
elle m’a menée jusqu’en Guyane,
comment elle a changé ma vie
et je vais vous faire une proposition
qui va peut-être changer la vôtre.
Tout a commencé, en fait,
pendant mes études de droit à la faculté.
J’entendais toutes les informations
sur le réchauffement climatique,
l’extinction de la biodiversité
et je me disais que le droit,
c’était l’outil magique pour agir,
parce qu’il y avait d’un côté les gentils,
ceux qui respectaient la loi,
et puis, de l’autre côté  les méchants,
les hors-la-loi, justement.
Alors quand j’ai eu mon diplôme d’avocat,
je n’attendais que ça :
pouvoir me mettre en marche,
pouvoir porter des recours en justice
contre ces grands pollueurs
et les mettre à genoux.
Sauf qu’en fait, ça ne s’est pas
tout à fait passé comme ça.
J’ai pris la liste des dix meilleurs
cabinets d’avocats
en droit de l’environnement.
J’ai envoyé mon CV et je me suis lancée.
Sauf que voilà,
mon dernier entretien d’embauche,
c’était dans un grand cabinet
d’avocats prestigieux à Paris,
sur les Champs Élysées.
J’avais en face de moi deux personnes
qui ont regardé mon dossier,
dans lequel j’avais inscrit
tous mes engagements associatifs.
Je pensais que c'était un atout
majeur dans ma candidature.
Et là, ils se sont regardés,
ils m’ont regardée, et ils m’ont dit :
« Mais mademoiselle, vous êtes chez
les méchants ici, vous savez. »
C’est à ce moment-là que j’ai compris que,
finalement, ces grands cabinets d’avocats
qui étaient étiquetés green, écolo,
en fait, ils n’étaient pas si green que ça
et défendaient ces grands méchants.
Et alors,
c’est comme ça que
j’ai décidé finalement de ne pas -
évidemment, déjà, je n’ai pas eu le poste,
mais en plus de ça, je n’ai pas insisté.
J’aurais pu évidemment rayer de la liste
toutes ces mentions inutiles
sur mes engagements associatifs
et faire plaisir à mes parents
avec un boulot
au bout de toutes ces années d’études.
Mais il se trouve que mon engagement
et tous ces rêves de justice climatique,
de justice écologique, étaient un peu
en train de battre de l’aile.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que j’avais porté un recours contre
la centrale nucléaire de Flamanville,
qui avait été balayé par le juge
d’un revers de main.
Je m’étais engagée à fond
dans le referendum contre l’aéroport
de Notre-Dame-des-Landes.
Pareil, on venait de le perdre.
Et puis, je commençais franchement
à fatiguer d’aller chaque année
dans les mêmes manifs,
que ce soit pour marcher pour le climat,
pour marcher contre Monsanto,
ou que sais-je.
Alors, quand on m’a proposé
de partir en Guyane
et d’aller travailler avec
des peuples autochtones, j’ai dit oui,
parce que c’étaient des peuples qui font
face à un nombre grand de dangers
sur cette planète,
qui, à la fois faisaient face à
l’accaparement de leurs territoires,
qui faisaient face à la destruction
de leur identité culturelle,
mais qui faisaient face aussi
à des écocides très concrets
qui affectent leurs rivières
et leurs forêts.
Alors voilà , au final, je me suis dit
peut-être que là-bas, j’aillais trouver
des réponses sur comment ça se fait,
qu’eux ont peut-être réussi
à préserver ce lien à la nature qui,
chez nous, semble aussi distendu.
Alors, j’ai troqué le métro
contre la pirogue,
j’ai laissé mon code de l’environnement
à Paris et je suis partie.
Là-bas, il se trouve que pour une petite
avocate parisienne comme moi,
tout avait l’air complètement
surdimensionné.
Je parle d’arbres centenaires immenses,
de fleuves majestueux de plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres de long.
Même le temps n’avait plus
la même taille, la même dimension.
Pour aller d’un village à l’autre,
parfois, il fallait plusieurs
jours en pirogue.
C’était aussi la première fois que
je voyais une nature aussi belle,
aussi présente,
elle était absolument partout.
Elle était à la fois magnifique,
comme ce soir-là, justement,
dans le village amérindien de Taluen,
sur le Haut-Maroni.
Parfois, elle était aussi
sacrément étrange.
Ça, c'est un coq de roche.
C’est une espèce très rare qui ne niche
qu’à quelques endroits en Guyane.
Et puis, parfois, elle est aussi un peu
effrayante, comme sur cette image.
C’est un serpent que j’ai croisé dans une
de mes excursions en forêt amazonienne.
Et il se trouve que, justement,
toute cette forêt magnifique,
toute cette nature,
elle m’a aussi appris à me réinventer,
à inventer une nouvelle façon de vivre.
J'ai dû apprendre à faire des nœuds sur
mon hamac pour pouvoir dormir le soir.
J’ai dû apprendre à me déplacer
différemment en pirogue
et même manger différemment.
Et prendre mon bain dans un fleuve
pour la première fois
a complètement changé ma vie.
J’ai eu beaucoup de chance
parce que là-bas, j’ai aussi trouvé
des personnes qui m’ont appris tout ça,
qui m’ont appris, grâce à un juriste
amérindien, le droit autochtone.
Alexis Tiouka, qui a été mon mentor,
est un spécialiste du droit autochtone,
m’a amenée dans chaque village amérindien
pour que j’apprenne leur histoire,
pour qu’à leur contact,
je comprenne leurs coutumes.
Leurs coutumes, c’est leur droit à eux
qui régit de manière ancestrale
la manière dont ils vivent ensemble,
dont ils sont organisés.
Et cette organisation sociale,
traditionnellement,
elle repose sur l’égalité entre tous,
mais aussi la symbiose avec la nature.
Alors attention, évidemment,
je ne suis pas ici pour vous vendre
le tableau idéal et idyllique
d’une population de peuples premiers,
ou pour faire un tableau paradisiaque
d’une autre civilisation
susceptible de devenir une sorte de
fétichisme pour les écologistes parisiens.
L’idée, ce n’est pas ça.
C’est de nous interroger vis-à-vis d’eux.
Mais quel est notre rapport à la nature ?
Quelle est la place de la nature
dans notre imaginaire collectif ?
Comment avons-nous institué
la nature dans notre société ?
Comment nous la reconnaissons ?
Et voilà un peu ce que
j’ai découvert là-bas.
Aujourd’hui, ce qui m’a marquée le plus
dans cette relation à la nature,
c’est leur lutte.
Parce que, vous en avez très
certainement entendu parler,
les peuples autochtones,
même si aujourd’hui ils sont devenus
des Français à part entière,
même s’ils ont été colonisés,
ils ont gardé ce lien à la nature
et ils continuent à se battre.
Et des revendications, je peux vous dire
qu’ils en ont beaucoup.
Quand je suis arrivée en Guyane,
c’était au même moment que
le projet Montagne d’or.
C’est un projet qui ressemble
beaucoup à celui-ci,
un projet de fosses immenses
au milieu de la forêt amazonienne,
dans lequel on aurait pu
tout simplement poser la tour Eiffel.
Ça représente 12 tonnes d’explosifs
par jour, 140 000 litres d’eau par heure,
plusieurs millions de tonnes
de boue rouge cyanurée.
Et tout ça, évidemment,
dans l’optique de piller la nature.
Alors, les autochtones de Guyane,
évidemment, ils se sont levés,
ils ont dit non à ce projet,
que c’était absolument impensable d’avoir
une telle destruction de la nature
et de proposer en retour une compensation
en plantant quelques arbres.
De la même façon, il se trouve que
le comble de ce projet, l’irrespect total,
c’était qu’en plus, ils avaient
installé ce projet de mine industrielle
sur une zone sacrée, un territoire sacré
pour les peuples autochtones,
parce qu’il regorge de vestiges
ancestraux amérindiens.
Les peuples autochtones,
très légitimement, ont dit :
« Mais est-ce que vous vous imaginez
si nous, on venait chez vous, en Europe,
et qu’on creusait dans vos cimetières,
qu’on sortait vos morts, vos bijoux ?»
Alors, avec le collectif Hors de question,
on s’est mobilisés, comme sur cette image,
où on marchait aux côtés de la
jeunesse autochtone de Guyane,
avec ces T-shirt en rouge, on était devant
la mairie de Cayenne et on protestait.
Et pour moi, ce projet, en fait, c’était
d’une certaine manière, un peu le symbole
de ce qui ne va pas dans notre société.
C’est-à-dire que d’un côté, vous aviez
ces peuples qui ont intériorisé,
qui ont conscience
qu’ils appartiennent à la nature,
et de l’autre côté, ces multinationales,
qui, elles, pensent que
la nature leur appartient.
Et ce que j’ai appris en observant
à travers leurs yeux ce processus,
c’était que les défauts de notre société
venaient du fait
qu’il y a ces multinationales, produits de
notre vision occidentale anthropocentrée,
extractivistes, c’est-à-dire
qui prenait à la Terre
pour assouvir des besoins humains
même pas essentiels parfois,
comme l’or justement,
et qui ne rendaient jamais en retour.
En tant que juriste, je vous avoue que
ce fut encore une sacrée déconvenue
parce que le droit ne fut absolument
d’aucune utilité dans notre combat.
Le droit, il était taillé sur mesure pour
satisfaire les besoins des industriels.
C’est comme s’il avait été écrit
pour dérouler le tapis rouge
au projet Montagne d’or
et à ces autres projets miniers.
En fait, ce qui nous a permis
de vraiment faire la bascule
et ce qui me permet aujourd’hui de dire
qu’on pourrait avoir gagné
contre le projet Montagne d’or,
c’est avant tout
parce qu’on a su se mobiliser.
En tant que citoyens,
on a su aller dans la rue,
on a mis la pression, que ce soit
politique, sociale, médiatique.
On y est allé et on a renversé
le rapport de force.
On a fait en sorte qu’on se fasse entendre
et Emmanuel Macron a dû bloquer ce projet.
Alors, voilà, du coup,
quelle conclusion en tirer ?
Eh bien, forcément,
il se trouve que en tant que juriste,
je me dis qu’il faut continuer, désobéir,
remettre en question ces règles,
en trouver des nouvelles
et mettre en place de nouveaux
mécanismes pour défendre le vivant.
Et dans cette lutte, les peuples
autochtones sont une inspiration pour moi,
extrêmement grande.
Il se trouve que le Mouvement mondial pour
la reconnaissance des droits de la nature
prend son envol actuellement.
Par exemple, en Nouvelle-Zélande,
les peuples Maori ont reconnu, grâce
à une loi, les droits de leur fleuve,
le fleuve Whanganui,
et ont obtenu d’être les tuteurs
légaux de ce fleuve.
De l’autre côté de la planète,
le peuple Yurok a adopté un texte
dans lequel il reconnaît
les droits du fleuve Klamath.
Il se reconnaît lui-même gardien
parce qu’il constate qu’en fait,
cette nature fait partie de sa famille
et ils ont ce sentiment
de filiation avec lui.
Je ne peux pas vous dresser une liste
car elle serait immense,
de toutes les décisions, de toutes
les jurisprudences qu’il y a déjà eu
pour la reconnaissance
des droits de la nature.
Vous le savez, aujourd’hui, les droits
de la nature sont en train de devenir
un mouvement massif au niveau mondial,
et nous nous en inspirons.
Alors voilà, si vous vous demandez
maintenant ce que c’est, en fait,
être gardien, être tuteur de la nature,
je vous répondrai qu’être gardien,
ce n’est pas être
un bon petit propriétaire.
Avec le recul, on sait
maintenant que, hélas,
la propriété privée n’est pas un moyen
de garantir la bonne gestion de la nature.
Et de la même façon,
être gardien de la nature, ce n’est pas
non plus être un bon petit citoyen
qui va régulièrement voter,
tout ça pour déléguer ensuite
la protection de la nature à d’autres,
à des représentants politiques chargés
de la défense de notre habitat naturel.
Pour moi, être gardien, c’est
véritablement garder ses prérogatives,
être codécisionnaire quand
il s’agit de protéger l’environnement.
mais aussi s’opposer à des lois injustes,
quand il se trouve
qu’on est face à des écocides.
Et si vous vous demandez :
« Maintenant qu’on a compris
ce que c’est être gardien,
comment fait-on ?
Parce que personnellement, on n’est ni
des scientifiques, ni des experts.
Peut-être même qu’on ne sait pas vraiment
comment fonctionne la nature. »
Je vais vous demander de faire
un petit pas de côté, cinq minutes,
parce qu’il se trouve
qu’il y a quelques mois,
je suis devenue gardienne
d’un autre être vivant.
Je n’avais absolument aucune
connaissance, aucun diplôme.
Avec mon copain, on a eu cette idée
un peu dingue de faire un enfant.
Voilà, je suis gardienne de ce petit être,
c’est-à-dire que, jusqu’à sa majorité,
c’est moi qui vais
le représenter en justice.
C’est moi qui vais prendre
des décisions à sa place
pour garantir ses meilleurs intérêts.
Et évidemment, ce n’est pas parce que
je suis particulièrement douée pour ça.
C’est parce qu’en fait,
j’ai ce lien d’amour avec lui.
Si on se basait uniquement sur
la compétence pour pouvoir dire
qui est légitime pour être gardien,
alors on ne confierait pas nos enfants à
des parents fraîchement émoulus comme moi.
On les confierait à des médecins,
des pédiatres, des sages-femmes.
Mais non.
Ce qui garantit qu’on est légitime,
c’est parce qu’on a ce lien d’amour,
ce lien de filiation avec d’autres êtres,
des êtres non humains
ou des êtres humains.
Et si vous êtes d’accord avec ça,
alors a contrario, vous serez peut-être
d’accord aussi avec le fait de dire que,
aujourd’hui, si je mets
en danger mon enfant,
si je prends des décisions
qui lui portent préjudice,
l’État peut me priver de la garde,
peut le placer sous la tutelle
de quelqu’un d’autre.
Je crois qu’on en est un peu là,
aussi pour la nature.
Des générations
et des années de politiques,
tous ces gouvernements
successifs nous ont démontré
qu’ils étaient complètement incapables
de prendre soin de la nature,
de prendre de vraies décisions
pour protéger l’environnement,
pour garantir la conservation
des écosystèmes
pour les générations futures.
Alors, ne croyez-vous pas
qu’il serait temps que nous,
on reprenne la tutelle sur la nature
et on se déclare gardiens ?
À travers ce nouveau mode
de représentation de la nature,
ce que j’aimerais, c’est que ces gardiens
et ces gardiennes de la nature
aient une vraie place,
un rôle dans notre société
lorsqu’ils s’engagent
pour défendre le vivant.
Personnellement,
je ne suis même pas sûre,
aujourd’hui, d’être une gardienne
de la nature accomplie.
Ce n'est pas ça la question.
Je suis sur ce cheminement.
Depuis que je suis rentrée de Guyane,
je m’attelle, notamment aux côtés de
la Convention citoyenne pour le climat,
à obtenir la reconnaissance en droit
français du crime d’écocide.
J’ai aussi fondé une école
qui s’appelle Wild Legal,
c’est une école des droits de la nature
qui s’engage pour faire en sorte que,
demain, chacun puisse avoir les outils
pour protéger les droits de la nature.
C’est un droit positif,
c’est un droit créatif,
c’est un droit qui se fiche de
savoir ce qui est légal ou illégal.
C’est un droit qui se demande
ce qui est enviable.
Moi, j’ai le droit, en tant que
juriste de me dire :
«Que fait-on avec ces données
qu’on a de la science ?
Que fait-on avec
ces savoirs autochtones ?»,
de faire table rase et créer un monde
nouveau plus enviable pour nos enfants.
Alors, si vous êtes d’accord avec tout ça,
sachez que vous n’êtes pas seuls.
C’est un mouvement mondial aujourd’hui.
Je vous invite à vous poser la question :
de quel écosystème
êtes-vous le plus proche ?
Quel est celui avec lequel
vous avez ce lien intime ?
Est-ce que c’est un fleuve, le fleuve
de votre enfance, un lac, une rivière,
une montagne ou même
une autre espèce animale ?
Est-ce que vous avez ce lien
qui vous permet de vous dire
que demain, vous voulez bien endosser
ce rôle de gardien de la nature.
Si c'est le cas, rejoignez le mouvement.
À vous de jouer.
(Applaudissements)